Now let's build the
document-term matrix
for our corpus.
So we'll create
a variable called
dtm that contains the
DocumentTermMatrix(corpus).
The corpus has already had all
the pre-processing run on it.
So to get the summary statistics
about the document-term matrix,
we'll just type in the
name of our variable, dtm.
And what we can see
is that even though we
have only 855 emails
in the corpus,
we have over 22,000 terms
that showed up at least once,
which is clearly
too many variables
for the number of
observations we have.
So we want to remove
the terms that
don't appear too
often in our data set,
and we'll do that using the
remove sparse terms function.
And we're going to have
to determine the sparsity,
so we'll say that we'll remove
any term that doesn't appear
in at least 3% of the documents.
To do that, we'll pass 0.97
to remove sparse terms.
Now we can take a look
at the summary statistics
for the document-term
matrix, and we
can see that we've decreased
the number of terms
to 788, which is a much
more reasonable number.
So let's build a data frame
called labeledTerms out
of this document-term matrix.
So to do this, we'll
use as.data.fram
of as.matrix applied to dtm,
the document-term matrix.
So this data frame is
only including right now
the frequencies of the words
that appeared in at least 3%
of the documents, but in order
to run our text analytics
models, we're also going to
have the outcome variable, which
is whether or not each
email was responsive.
So we need to add in
this outcome variable.
So we'll create
labeledTerms$responsive,
and we'll simply copy over
the responsive variable from
the original emails
data frame so it's equal
to emails$responsive.
So finally let's take a look
at our newly constructed data
frame with the str function.
So as we expect, turn off a
lot of variables, 789 in total.
788 of those variables
are the frequencies
of various words in the emails,
and the last one is responsive,
the outcome variable.